Tradutor: Sonia Mendes
Revisor: Maricene Crus
Como ser inovador, ter grandes ideias
e criar grandes negócios?
Acho que essa pergunta
está na cabeça de muita gente aqui.
O tema inovação hoje está na pauta
principal de pequenas e grandes empresas.
Mas, o que é inovar?
A gente é inovador, de fato, quando pega
nossas ideias e as coloca em prática,
ou seja, tira as ideias do papel.
Mas quando a gente está pensando
e tendo ideias e mais ideias,
na realidade, a gente só está sendo
criativo, e não inovador de fato.
Inovador é aquele que pega
as ideias e as aplica.
Mas ter ideias inovadoras,
mexer com a sociedade
e com as grandes corporações,
isso é muito difícil. Temos muitas
barreiras pra fazer isso acontecer.
Uma das principais barreiras
que a gente encontra hoje,
na realidade, são as pessoas.
São aqueles que vou apelidar
de "os âncoras".
Quando um navio chega num porto
ou a algum ponto no mar,
e ele quer ficar parado, o que ele faz?
Lança uma âncora.
A âncora impede o navio de se movimentar.
Ela faz o navio ficar parado,
em uma mesma posição.
Quando eu falo de âncoras, na verdade
estou falando desses âncoras aqui.
São aquelas pessoas que, ao ouvir
aquelas ideias ousadas, transformadoras,
que pedem que a gente faça
as coisas de forma diferente,
elas falam "não", porque elas estão
acostumadas a fazer as coisas
daquele mesmo jeito que sempre fizeram.
Os âncoras enxergam como fizemos
as coisas no passado,
e acham que o futuro
vai ser igual ao passado,
basta repetir o que fizemos e, no futuro,
a mesma coisa vai acontecer.
Porém, hoje vivemos
num mundo transformador.
As coisas mudam muito rapidamente.
E pensar que o futuro será igual
ao passado é um erro muito cruel.
O segundo ponto são as ideias.
A gente não pode pensar que as boas ideias
aparecem logo de primeira,
assim de cara, ideias geniais
aparecem como num flash.
Na realidade, as primeiras
ideias são horríveis.
Quantas vezes não tivemos
ideias horríveis da primeira vez?
O fato é que essas ideias nascem meio
estranhas, pequenas, mas elas evoluem.
E os âncoras, os anti-criativos,
são os caras que descartam essas ideias.
A gente tem que considerar
a evolução das ideias.
Elas amadurecem, se lapidam, crescem.
Existem também as ideias
que estão [à frente] do seu tempo.
São as ideias que aparecem agora,
mas não fazem muito sentido.
Mas lá na frente, com a vida mudando,
elas passam a fazer total sentido.
Sobre as ideias, tem outro ponto
muito importante.
Se a gente vive num ambiente
suficientemente criativo,
existe uma probabilidade bem grande
de que uma outra ideia,
que habita um contexto completamente
diferente, se choque com a nossa ideia.
E dessa fusão de ideias, nasce
uma ideia muito maior e melhor
do que as duas outras que nós tínhamos.
Isso é fantástico. A gente não pode
descartar o poder que as ideias podem ter.
Mas não vivemos somente de ideias.
Precisamos de um processo.
Uma forma fácil de enxergar
um processo de inovação
é compará-lo a um processo de dissolução
de problemas convencional,
em que temos um problema,
pode ser um apresentado pra gente,
ou um problema que a gente vive,
ou enxerga que a sociedade vive.
Existe o terceiro tipo que é
um problema que os visionários enxergam.
São aqueles problemas
que a gente não sabe que tem.
A gente tem, mas não percebeu,
não sabe como a vida pode ser diferente.
Isso a gente vê hoje em dia.
Tem muitas coisas que usamos hoje e não
imaginávamos ter 10 ou 20 anos atrás.
Hoje pensamos assim:
"Como eu podia viver daquela forma?"
Porém, quando olhamos pra esse processo
de inovação em solução de problemas,
principalmente, na parte de encontrar
o problema e achar uma boa ideia,
na realidade, só estamos olhando
para ponta do iceberg.
É como olhar para uma árvore e dar
atenção às folhas e flores desta árvore.
Que tal se a gente tentasse olhar
pras raízes da árvore?
Ou seja, qual é o ecossistema
criativo que gera inovação?
Um ecossistema bom, criativo, inovador,
é um ecossistema em que conseguimos
balancear bem esses três elementos:
as pessoas, a tecnologia e os métodos.
Quando eu falo de pessoas, não me refiro
àquele gênio do livro de histórias,
aquela figura descabelada, que fica horas
trancada no quarto, no laboratório,
pesquisando ali um fundamento, uma ciência
e, repentinamente, aparece
com uma grande ideia.
É claro que esses gênios trouxeram
várias coisas que temos nos nossos dias,
não podemos negar esses gênios.
Mas estou falando
de um outro tipo de gênio.
Os talentos da geração digital.
São aquelas pessoas talentosas que olham
pros problemas e enxergam oportunidades.
São aquelas que estudam tecnologia,
e sabem usar as ferramentas em mãos
pra criar algo realmente novo.
São desses gênios que estou falando.
Mas, não estou falando só de pessoas;
na realidade, estou falando de times.
As pessoas não fazem nada sozinhas.
Os bons times são aqueles diversificados,
pessoas que conseguem olhar pro problema
por diversos ângulos diferentes.
Os times formados dessa forma são
muito mais poderosos e mais criativos.
Mas tem um ponto importante:
pessoas inteligentes e criativas,
às vezes são difíceis de se lidar.
Elas têm uma opinião
muito forte, muito própria,
elas têm dificuldade
de se expressar, de se relacionar.
É por isso que a gente,
muitas vezes, cai naquela armadilha
de formar times com pessoas
que são imagem e semelhança,
pessoas iguaizinhas.
Elas pensam igual, fizeram o mesmo curso,
vieram do mesmo lugar, tem a mesma idade
mais ou menos, tem a mesma cultura,
elas falam até mesmo a mesma língua.
Não vou negar que é possível
formar times inovadores dessa forma,
mas é importante a gente ter noção
de que um time formado
por pessoas que têm o mesmo olhar
acaba tendo um raio de criatividade
e inovação muito mais limitado.
É preciso dar atenção à diversidade.
O pensamento fora da caixa
e a criatividade
vai ser muito mais provável
se misturarmos pessoas diferentes,
que olham o problema de forma diferente,
com diferentes experiências de vida,
diferentes formações.
Aí sim, neste caso a gente torna muito
mais natural aquela colisão de ideias.
E essa colisão de ideias
é mais importante.
É essa colisão que traz as grandes ideias.
E quando falam de tecnologia...
Hoje a tecnologia avança
em ritmo e velocidades exponenciais.
Temos inteligência artificial,
com máquinas que aprendem,
máquinas que nos compreendem,
que são autônomas,
drones, robôs, carros autônomos,
realidade virtual, realidade
aumentada, holografia...
São tecnologias que nos transportam
pra um mundo imersivo.
E tem muito mais: internet das coisas,
milhares de sensores, os wearables, nossa!
Tudo isso parece coisa do futuro, mas não.
Isso está acontecendo logo agora, hoje.
Em um estalar de dedos,
já vai ser passado.
Isso vai deixar de existir
e outras coisas vão acontecer.
A gente não pode ignorar, hoje em dia,
a velocidade com que a tecnologia avança.
É uma velocidade nunca vista antes.
Antes, as coisas não eram
tão rápidas assim.
Vamos ver um exemplo:
pra atingir 50 milhões de pessoas,
o telefone levou 75 anos.
Pro mesmo grupo de 50 milhões de pessoas,
o rádio levou apenas 38 anos.
A TV, 13 anos.
A internet foi muito rápida;
em quatro anos atingiu esse público.
Mas, veja bem,
o game Angry Birds Space conseguiu
50 milhões de downloads em só 35 dias.
É muito rápido, né?
A velocidade com que as coisas evoluem
é de uma rapidez fantástica.
A gente não pode ignorar essa velocidade.
E mais: a velocidade com que a tecnologia
transforma as coisas.
Hoje a gente fala muito
em tecnologias disruptivas,
que mudam e transformam o negócio.
A gente olha os exemplos de negócios
que apareceram e desapareceram,
que foram transformados
pelo mundo digital.
E podemos pensar, às vezes, que essa
transformação é uma exclusividade de hoje,
do mundo digital, que vai
transformar todas as coisas.
Mas não!
O que transforma é a ciência,
a tecnologia e as grandes ideias.
Eu vou trazer um exemplo
de dois séculos atrás.
No final do século 19,
grandes cidades do mundo, como Nova York,
dependiam de milhares de cavalos,
que ficavam nas ruas
e transportavam pessoas e produtos.
O número de cavalo foi aumentando
conforme a demanda da cidade
e começou a trazer um problema
que estava preocupando a sociedade:
o esterco, isso mesmo, o esterco.
O que acontece é que cada cavalo produzia,
por dia, entre 6 e 15 kg de esterco.
No ano de 1894, estima-se que Nova York
tinha uma população de 100 mil cavalos.
Esses 100 mil cavalos depositavam
todos os dias nas ruas de Nova York
mais de uma tonelada de esterco.
Vejam o problema que estavam enfrentando.
A população estava muito preocupada
e começava a haver previsões
catastróficas sobre a cidade.
Como seria a cidade com o número de
cavalos aumentando, mais esterco nas ruas,
mais doenças, sujeira?
Como seria a cidade
dali a 20, 30, 50 anos?
Alguns diziam que a quantidade de esterco
na rua poderia chegar ao terceiro andar
de um prédio em Manhattan.
(Risos)
Quatro anos depois, em 1898,
Nova York sediou a Primeira Conferência
Internacional de Planejamento Urbano.
E nessa conferência o assunto
principal era os cavalos,
ou melhor, o esterco dos cavalos.
Os líderes do mundo todo
discutiram por vários dias
como poderiam resolver esse problema,
mas não chegaram a nenhuma conclusão,
não tinha uma solução para aquilo.
Todo mundo sabe aqui que Nova York
não foi inundada por esterco.
Isso não aconteceu.
A questão é que havia uma solução
tecnológica, de longo prazo,
que estava sendo criada,
e ninguém percebia.
Aproximadamente uma década depois,
Henry Ford conseguiu um processo
de produção de carros,
que fazia carros a preços mais baratos.
Ele produzia em escala.
E a sociedade começou a comprar carros.
E a medida que ela comprava carros,
diminuía o número de cavalos.
E hoje sabemos o resto da história,
que são as grandes cidades de hoje em dia.
É muito importante vermos que a tecnologia
transforma as coisas, a sociedade,
e, muitas vezes, não conseguimos
enxergar o problema que temos.
As coisas acontecem debaixo
do nosso nariz.
Vou falar sobre método.
Quando a gente junta paixão, conhecimento,
e a gente canaliza a criatividade
das pessoas pra resolver um problema,
aí temos a criatividade de fato.
Podemos usar atividades de ideação, como
"hackathons", sessões de "brainstorming",
que são atividades que tiram
as pessoas da zona de conforto
e fazem o espírito criativo aflorar.
Mas, e quando a gente não tem
todos esses três elementos,
tem apenas dois deles, por exemplo?
E se tivermos só pessoas e tecnologia,
faltando método, uma organização?
O que acontece é que acabamos
tendo um processo caótico.
São ideias soltas, sem objetivo.
Ideias que não servem pra nada,
como a gente costuma falar.
Por outro lado, se temos
pessoas e métodos,
mas não dominamos a tecnologia,
que é o que nos encanta hoje em dia,
é o diferencial dos nossos produtos,
A gente acaba tendo produtos simples,
parece que falta alguma coisa.
É uma coisa insuficiente.
E se faltam as pessoas?
A mente criativa, que pensa fora da caixa,
que pensa na forma diferente de fazer.
Nossos produtos acabam
sendo apenas triviais.
Bom, promover ideias,
criar um ambiente com liberdade
de expressão e criativo,
investir em pessoas com diversidades,
pessoas diferentes, que pensam diferente,
e que o todo faz algo maior,
investir em conhecimento de tecnologias,
tecnologias que vão transformar o mundo.
Claro, ter um método que consiga
canalizar a criatividade das pessoas
em cima de uma estratégia, de um objetivo.
Esses são os alicerces da inovação.
Obrigado, pessoal.
( Aplausos)